all right let's start um with some big
but expected news so i don't have that
much more to say about it than i've
already said because this is exactly
what we've been expecting
um
joe biden's voting rights bill
seems to be dead because democrats have
been unable to change the filibuster
which very clearly became a prerequisite
to really be able to do the voting
rights bill and this is exactly what we
expected so i don't know how much there
is to say but as the associated press
press's reporting voting bill collapses
democrats unable to change filibuster
voting legislation that democrats and
civil rights leaders say is vital to
protecting democracy that's true it is
collapsed when two senators refused to
join their own party in changing senate
rules to overcome a republican
filibuster after a raw emotional debate
who are those two senators well i'm sure
many of you know they are democratic
senator joe manchin and democratic
senator kirsten cinema the outcome
wednesday night says the ap was a
stinging defeat for president biden and
his party coming at the tumultuous close
to his first year in office yeah almost
to the day biden said in a statement
after the vote i am profoundly
disappointed but that he is quote not
deterred and vowed to quote explore
every measure and use every tool at our
disposal to stand up for democracy so
the question now is what can be done via
executive order
to maybe
put in place
some elements of what would have been in
the voting rights bill but mansion and
cinema's
positions on this
not a surprise and the idea of changing
the filibuster remember was to reduce
the threshold
for debating the voting rights bill from
60. when you have 50 democrats and you
need 60 votes you need 10 republicans
this is pretty simple math the idea of
changing the filibuster was the chant to
change the requirement of 60 in order to
do that they needed all 50 democrats
they didn't have them the filibuster
doesn't change and thus there is at this
time no path forward for the voting
rights legislation now i think it's
important
that you know when we talked about
leading into the 2016 election
there were these people uh uh who who
should be really crawling into a hole
and never being heard from again uh in
terms of their opinions who were saying
hillary trump it's not really going to
make a difference it's all it's all kind
of the same
uh if it's not a real progressive i
don't want the person uh it doesn't
really matter
uh and we said well but sir ma'am what
about the supreme court what about all
these different things
look at the supreme court at this point
in time look at all the things look at
the disasters that ended up happening
under donald trump so we've got to
remember that at the same time we have
to remember now
uh that
this is a fundamental
building block of our democracy
republicans have made it clear they've
abandoned policy they've abandoned
convincing people that their ideas are
good they merely want to win on
obstructing democrats
and using
uh
voter suppression
and various um uh other tactics to make
it more difficult to vote to try to win
elections and then if you don't win try
to steal the election that's what they
do now and so when something like this
gets stalled in its tracks hopefully joe
biden can do some of this via executive
order we don't yet know we have to see
but remember these kind of turning
points and one of those was
hillary trump how bad could trump really
be let's send a message let's shake it
up wow what a disastrous four years
we've got to be thinking along those
same lines here
one of our sponsors is curiosity stream
the only streaming service dedicated to
documentaries and when you use my link
below you can get curiosity stream for
just 15 bucks a year i've been using
curiosity stream for almost a year now
it's become my go-to app for video
entertainment i've always found
curiosity stream as a better selection
of documentaries than netflix hulu or
amazon they have documentaries on
politics economics history technology
psychology really everything i just
finished watching the celts about
the celts a group i did not know a lot
about
fascinating curiosity stream always has
the newest and most critically acclaimed
titles you can watch on any device and
curiosity stream is giving my audience
25 off a subscription which comes out to
just 15 bucks a year go to
curiositystream.com pacman the link is
down below